Trascrizione: Caterina Carraro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
E se Leonardo avesse avuto
una stampante 3D?
Immaginate se Leonardo,
nel suo laboratorio
avesse avuto a disposizione
questa tecnologia.
Leonardo è sicuramente "L'uomo, il genio";
ma Guglielmo Marconi
che è un mio conterraneo, amava dire:
"Non credete all'esistenza dei geni:
esistono solo persone tenaci."
Quindi probabilmente Leonardo,
così come Guglielmo Marconi,
erano tenaci.
Tenace lo sono anch'io, nel mio piccolo:
ovviamente non come loro,
non ho la loro caratura -
però, vi racconto una breve storia.
La storia inizia in questo posto,
che l'officina di famiglia
dove facciamo macchine
automatiche speciali.
Lì era il 1980, avevo circa 12 anni;
e mio padre mi disse, un giorno:
sai se vuoi il mio posto -
il suo posto era
in ufficio, al primo piano -
devi farti tanta esperienza:
usò un altro termine, ovviamente.
Però dice: devi farti tanta esperienza.
giù, qui sotto in officina.
E ho detto: beh, allora almeno
utilizziamo l'estate,
quando non vado a scuola,
per cominciare questo percorso:
più ne faccio prima,
forse, prima ci arrivo.
Lui non aveva fretta
di mollare, eh, intendiamoci:
però, intanto ho fatto il mio percorso.
E dopo aver fatto
diversi lavori nell'officina,
quindi partendo dal magazzino,
ho fatto la logistica,
ho fatto tante altre cose,
e anche gli uffici, quant'altro.
Ho capito che dovevo crescere
il mio bagaglio,
la mia cassetta degli attrezzi
doveva avere altri strumenti.
Colgo l'occasione, una sfida,
e anche qui c'è voluta un po' di tenacia,
e mi trasferisco in America per un anno.
Lavoravo, gratis, di giorno
presso un'azienda
dove facevo uno stage formativo;
e alla sera andavo al college di DuPage.
Quando sono tornato a casa -
questo è il '94, sono tornato a casa -
volevo cambiare il mondo,
lo volevo proprio ribaltare completamente:
non era esattamente come l'avevo pensato
perché era molto più difficile,
soprattutto quando devi portare,
in aziende che sono vecchie,
perché hanno comunque una struttura
che è nata tanti anni prima,
delle novità:
non sempre ci riesci con la velocità
con cui le vuoi introdurre.
Però non mi fermo:
quindi, un giorno mi capita,
con un mio caro amico,
di vedere una tecnologia con lui.
Mio padre ovviamente era in società -
era il socio finanziatore,
sostanzialmente -
e iniziamo a fare simulazioni virtuali
con cinematismi applicati.
Circa un anno prima -
ma questo non lo sapevo,
l'ho saputo dopo, a livello storico -
era nata la Pixar.
Quindi non abbiamo fatto altro
che prendere una tecnologia dei videogame
e applicarla al mondo dell'industria.
In questo settore ci siamo applicati
su diverse grosse aziende,
e una di queste mi ha dato l'opportunità
di toccare per la prima volta, con mano,
un oggetto stampato in 3D.
Avevo già sentito questa tecnologia,
soprattutto in America,
che avevo un po' studiato,
però non avevo ancora
toccato quest'oggetto,
non capivo bene come poteva funzionare:
in origine, pensate che si chiamava
"stereolitografia", neanche stampa 3D.
Cosa è successo?
Che a questo punto mi sono ritrovato
nell'azienda di famiglia,
a dire: quello che io adesso faccio
quello che vedete lì in alto,
sono tre particolari meccanici
che compongono uno stesso pezzo,
che si chiama piegatore.
Come posso fare a mollare
il metodo produttivo tradizionale,
e passare alla stampa 3D?
Posso farlo? È economico?
C'era un percorso da fare,
quindi ho dovuto fare
ragionamenti, analisi,
con i tecnici e quant'altro,
e quindi ho deciso
che avrei iniziato, nel 2011,
un cambio tecnologico
in favore del metal additive.
Perché?
Perché col metodo Corsini -
non ho usato molta fantasia,
è il mio cognome -
lì ci sono gli oggetti
che voi vedete sopra stampati in 3D,
ovviamente in metallo.
Quindi io non avevo più tre oggetti
con le viti, il montaggio,
la distinta e quant'altro;
ma avevo un unico oggetto
che usciva dalla stampante.
Come poterlo fare?
Eh, ovviamente dovevo fare una ricerca,
dovevo capire quali erano le tecnologie
e se le tecnologie erano alla portata
di un'azienda meccanica,
perché ovviamente era sicuramente
alla portata di aziende che fanno aerei,
piuttosto che Aerospace,
dove i budget sono diversi;
ma l'azienda meccanica, alla fine,
deve far quadrare i conti.
e quindi, mi sono un attimo ingegnato
e qualche anno dopo, nel 2016,
dopo un po' di percorsi,
di analisi delle tecnologie
che si trovavano sul mercato,
la famiglia decise, visto
che facciamo macchine automatiche,
che "Make" era meglio di "Buy";
e quindi, ci siamo fatti questa macchina.
Ovviamente, anche qui,
tenacia, "Never give up":
andare a fondo, e cercare di capire.
Questa è la stampante 3D.
In questo caso,
stiamo stampando il nostro gadget
che diamo ai nostri clienti,
che sono dei tortellini -
vengo da Bologna,
che cosa potevo stampare?
Quindi, mi sono un attimo ingegnerizzato:
e visto che sono in INOX,
lo abbiamo chiamato
"tortellinox", con la X finale.
(Risate)
Andiamo avanti: lo vedete
qua in basso sulla destra.
Poi ci siamo fatti anche l'umarell,
che andava anche di moda;
a sinistra, come potete vedere,
ci sono le torri, le due torri di Bologna;
e in mezzo i pezzi meccanici,
perché in realtà quello era l'obiettivo:
il resto fa solo capire
qual è la capacità, a livello produttivo,
di questa tecnologia.
Quindi, sicuramente può fare
veramente la differenza;
ma torniamo  un attimo al ragionamento.
Poi cos'è successo,
cioè qual è stata la molla
che ci ha fatto arrivare
a quello che è il nostro
più grande successo,
cioè la stampante 3D per ottone?
Io vado presso un cliente
che è di Brescia,
è un caro imprenditore
che stimo moltissimo,
glii presento la stampante "Viper",
per acciai, per inox.
Mi dice: bella, fantastica -
ma lo fai l'ottone?
Io ho detto: "Non ancora:
però, se vado a casa,
cerco di capire come si fa,
e magari trovo il materiale" -
perché il problema era trovare
il materiale di origine,
per poterlo processare -
"ci possiamo provare".
In realtà, lui sapeva -
io no, ma lui lo sapeva
che era una domanda quasi impossibile:
ma io non lo sapevo,
e quindi ci ho provato lo stesso;
e poi, comunque, l'avrei presa
anche come sfida.
A questo punto, due anni
di tentativi, di prove,
di ricerca scientifica in collaborazione
con l'Università di Modena,
con tecnici, ragazzi fantastici -
veramente, ho un team incredibile -
si è arrivati a realizzare
la prima stampante 3D per ottone al mondo:
quindi un primato tutto italiano,
"Made in Pontecchio Marconi".
A destra vedete un oggetto finito,
c'è la classica valvola,
quindi anche valvole, rubinetti:
qualsiasi cosa viene fatta in ottone;
a destra, ci sono anche oggetti
come quelli che ho qua di fianco:
uno può fare una fibbia,
può fare qualsiasi cosa in ottone.
E quindi, non ha solo un uso industriale:
così come l'Inox, anche l'ottone
può avere usi non industriali.
Andiamo a Leonardo:
perché prima vi ho parlato di Leonardo,
e se avesse avuto una stampante 3D?
Immaginate Leonardo con una
stampante 3D in plastica:
avrebbe potuto, prima di andare
a costruire la sua magnifica scala,
provarla;
quindi avrebbe potuto stamparla piccolina,
e vederla se magari c'erano dei difetti.
Difetti non si son visti,
in quel che ha fatto -
però, per l'amor di Dio.
Dall'altra parte,
aveva anche la catapulta:
poteva anche provare se funzionava,
magari doveva dimensionare
diversamente alcuni pezzi;
oppure, addirittura, l'Uomo Vitruviano
lo poteva anche simulare in stampa 3D.
Oppure, poteva andare verso quello
che era un'esigenza di oggi,
ma immaginate che poteva essere
una esigenza di allora,
quindi poteva creare delle mascherine,
poteva creare degli strumenti,
degli attrezzi;
e dopo avrebbe, ovviamente,
fatto il passo successivo.
Ma qui stiamo parlando
di una stampante in plastica.
E se l'avesse avuta in acciaio?
magari avrebbe potuto costruire,
per il suo automa Cavaliere -
questa è stata fatta in acciaio -
la cotta di maglia, ok?
Quindi, avrebbe potuto costruire
degli oggetti che andavano
direttamente sul campo;
quindi, andavano direttamente -
anche degli strumenti,
poteva costruirci degli attrezzi speciali.
Perché vi parlo, soprattutto,
in generale, di stampa 3D
che ho fatto dalla plastica
agli acciai e all'ottone?
Perché la stampa 3D
è un mercato incredibile
che si sta sviluppando:
noi siamo in basso qui, a sinistra.
Questa è la progressione che ha
nei prossimi dieci anni:
quindi, siam partiti dal 2019, 2029.
Questo cosa significa?
Che in realtà ci sono nuove opportunità,
è un mercato che crescerà
in maniera spaventosa,
e ognuno di noi avrà a che fare
con questa tecnologia,
direttamente o indirettamente,
perché lo vuole o non lo vuole.
Adesso alcuni fanno
le protesi, in stampa 3D;
si fanno i denti, in stampa 3D;
e non è che tu vai dal dottore e dici.
"Ma è fatto in 3D o è normale?"
No, te lo decide lui: è lui, il dottore.
Quindi il concetto è:
vi dà nuove opportunità,
vi dà nuove professioni.
Quindi io quello che mi auguro
è che vi avviciniate a questa tecnologia.
Avvicinarsi come?
Regalatevi una stampante 3D,
una stampante piccolina;
regalate, se non a voi
anche a qualcuno dei vostri familiari.
Se avete un nipote, un figlio, qualcuno.
E poi, cominciate a conoscerla:
veramente, con poche - un entry level,
non c'è niente di incredibile:
però, continuate a conoscere
questa tecnologia
perché è veramente importante
che voi capiate
che in futuro questa tecnologia
sarà una tecnologia
incredibilmente preponderante
in tutto quello che fate,
in tutto quello che sarà
lo sviluppo della vostra vita.
Questo perché?
Perché così come è successo per me,
che ho conosciuto
questa tecnologia per un'esigenza,
e ho cercato di capire,
di immaginarci un futuro,
e mi ha cambiato, letteralmente, la vita
e la vita della mia azienda,
spero che lo faccia altrettanto per voi:
quindi, quello che vi dico,
è che vi auguro,
che abbiate questo messaggio
come un incitamento
a studiare, ad approfondire,
ed essere curiosi e tenaci.
Quindi mai, mai mollare:
è la parola d'ordine, la tenacia.
Come diceva Marconi,
non crediate che ci siano dei geni:
è la tenacia, quella che fa la differenza.
Quindi io dico:
e se il nuovo Leonardo fossi tu?
Grazie.
(Applausi)